A GOOD AFTERNOON- WE WILL WAIT
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM BUT GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH SOME
LOGISTICS AND PROTOCOLS- FREDDIE
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC- THAT ARE
PRESENT IN THIS ROOM WE ARE
REQUIRING- SOME PHYSICAL DISEASE
SO PLEASE FOLLOW DIRECTIONS OF
OUR SERGEANTS AND POSTED- SOME
GUIDANCE THERE ARE EIGHT BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA THAT ARE ARE ARE
UNDER. THE CONSIDERATION BY OUR
COMMITTEE SIX OF WHICH ARE
PROPOSED AS PART OF A CONSENT
CALENDAR AND NOTE THAT ITEM
NUMBER SIX A. B. TWO FOUR FIVE
SEVEN- GRAY HAS BEEN PULLED FOR
THE REQUEST FOR EACH ITEM ON OUR
AGENDA THAT THERE WILL BE
OPPORTUNITY FULL COMMENT
COMMENTS MAY BE MADE IN PERSON
IN THIS ROOM OR BY PHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE TEN MINUTES FOR EACH
BILL THE PHONE NUMBER TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS WILL BE SHOWN TO
VIEWERS ON SCREEN. I'M AT THE
THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING AND IS
ALSO POSTED ON ASSEMBLY
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND I WAS GIVEN A NOTE HERE THAT
DUE TO ROOM- SHORTAGES PLEASE
USE ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN AGAIN ONE
THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN
WHEN CALLING IN. FOR ALL OF
THOSE WILL BE- MAKING SOME
COMMENTS THIS AFTERNOON WE ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND IF APPLICABLE THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT AND
IF YOU SUPPORTER OPPOSE A BILL
THAT IS BEING CONSIDERED. I'M OF
THE PUBLIC IS ALSO WELCOME TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS TO A
COMMITTEE TO EMAIL EMAIL TO BE
SENT TO THE ADDRESS FOUND ON OUR
WEBSITE WHICH IS A G. R. I. DOT
COMMITTEE AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
G. O. . IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
THE GOAL OF OUR HEARING- TWO. OF
OF DOING ALL WE CAN TO HEAR AS
MUCH OF THE PUBLIC WITH THE
LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE WILL NOT
PERMIT CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF- THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING THE WEATHER
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY- AND SO WITH
THAT WE WILL MOVE TO THE FIRST
BILL ON FILE- WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO ONE FIVE THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOAQUIN ARAMBULA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME TO
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE. AND YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
OTHER MEMBERS THANK YOU. TODAY
ON AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE STRETCHES
THE DOLLAR OF CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS EVEN FURTHER BY
COMBINING SUCCESSFUL FRUIT AND
VEGETABLE SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT
PROGRAMS WITH THE EFFICIENCIES
OF CALIFORNIA'S EBT SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING FOOD
INSECURITY AT ALARMING RATES AT
THE START OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIANS WERE
HAVING DIFFICULTY PUTTING FOOD
ON THE TABLE. IT IS EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WITH ONE IN FOUR
WHO ARE HAVING DIFFICULTIES WITH
AFFORDABLE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES. THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT WE CAN CHANGE THIS WHEN
PEOPLE HAVE THE MONEY TO
PURCHASE FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
THEY DO. A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
AROUND THE STATE'S CURRENTLY
PROVIDE DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR MATCH
TO CALFRESH RECIPIENTS
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I COULD ASK YOU
TO STOP HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND WE NEED TO.
TAKE A RECESS FOR ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES. WHAT WE KNOW. AND
HOLDING OUT THAT LONG. RIDLEY MY
HAMBURGER. TO SEE- OKAY MAYBE
SEVEN OTHER. OKAY OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER START. WHEN YOU ARE READY
THANK YOU. AS WE STATED A NUMBER
OF PROGRAMS AROUND THE STATE
CURRENTLY PROVIDE DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR MATCH TO CALIFORNIA'S
RECIPIENTS AT FARMERS MARKETS.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE
RECOGNIZES THE IMMENSE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF THESE MATCHING
PROGRAMS AND MEETS CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS WHERE THEY NORMALLY
PURCHASE PRODUCE. THE EXPANSION
WHICH IS PROPOSED WITHIN AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE WOULD
INCLUDE LARGE RETAIL CHAINS
CORNER STORES AND OTHER DIRECT
FARM TO CONSUMER ENTITIES THAT
SELL CALIFORNIA GROWN FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES. IMPORTANTLY THIS
BILL LEVERAGES THE EFFICIENCY OF
THE ET CARDS ALREADY USED BY
CALFRESH RECIPIENTS TO REDUCE
THE HASSLE AND TO MAKE ACCESSING
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THAT MUCH
EASIER FOR FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I AM JOINED TODAY BY
TAYLOR ROSHEN REPRESENTING THE
FARM BUREAU AND BY DAVID BARBER
DONE I'M A PARTICIPANT IN THE
MAS FRESCO PROGRAM IN SAN DIEGO
. I THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STRUCTURE WAS GREAT TO SEE YOU
HI GOOD AFTERNOON- CHEN MEMBERS
TO THE RUSSIAN THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU WE HEAR IN SUPPORT
OF TWENTY AND FIFTY THREE AND
THANK DR ARAMBULA AND THE
SPONSORS FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS-
AS THE SOME MEMBER NOTED THE
HEALTH BENEFITS THIS BILL- ARE
OBVIOUS. MAKING HEALTHY FOOD
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR ANY
POPULATION BUT PARTICULARLY FOOD
INSECURE I WILL HAVE
DEMONSTRABLE HEALTH BENEFITS IT
DOES THIS BY BUILDING ON THE
EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM TO
PURCHASE TO IMPROVE THE
PURCHASING POWER. OF THAT
BENEFIT RECIPIENTS AT A BROTHER
SPOKE A SWATH OF RETAILERS AS
MEMBER NOTED WE'VE GOT SOME
GREAT SUCCESS HAPPENING AT
CERTIFIED FARMERS MARKETS AND
IT'S NOW TIME TO TRANSITION THEM
TO LARGER RETAIL WHERE PEOPLE-
ACTUALLY ARE PURCHASING THEIR
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES- I'M
SURE YOU'VE ALL SEEN IT AT YOUR
OWN SUPERMARKET SHELVES
INFLATION'S HIT A ALL TIME HIGH
OF FORTY YEAR RECORD HIGH. AND
USD JUST REPORTED- A FEW DAYS
AGO THAT THE COST FOR FOOD TODAY
IS 10% HIGHER THAN THE COST WAS
LAST YEAR AT THE SAME TIME- SO
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT THAT MEANS
IS- MANY OF ARE FOOD INSECURE
FAMILIES ARE TRYING TO STRETCH
THEIR DOLLARS FURTHER. AND HAVE
TO MAKE SOME TOUGH CHOICES ABOUT
WHAT THEY BUY WHEN THEY EAT AND
HOW MUCH THEY EATEN OFTENTIMES
THAT MEANS THEY'RE NOT BUYING-
FRESHFRUITS AND VEGETABLES
ESPECIALLY NOT CALIFORNIA GROUND
SO WHAT WE FEEL LIKE THIS BILL
DOES IS IT REALLY SEEKS TO MAKE
THAT CHOICE A LITTLE EASIER- AND
IT'S REALLY A WIN FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND A WIN FOR THE
FARMERS I'M IN CALIFORNIA THAT
SELL INTO THOSE MARKETS SO. IN
DOING THAT WE THINK WE EMPOWER
ALL PARTS OF THE COMMUNITY AND
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE WE
REQUESTED AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR TO MONEY MISS
RUSSIA NO WE HAVE- MISTER DAVID
BARBER VIA TELEPHONE TO OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE- DISH- MAKE SURE
TO. CONNECT- MISTER BARBER WHO
AGAIN WILL BE TESTING IN SUPPORT
OF TWO ONE FIVE THREE. THEY'RE
CONNECTED IN THEIR LINE IS OPEN
. THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM DAVID BOWE
BERGDAHL NUMBER BY REAL MEN
DOING SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO COUNTY I'M ON A LIMITED
INCOME WITH SOCIAL SECURITY AND
HEALTH CONDITIONS BECAUSE OF
WORKING IN LABOR FOR YEARS.
BEFORE MY FIRST GOAL I WOULD
RATHER NOT A CAN OF BEANS TODAY
BECAUSE MOST OF MY SOCIAL
SECURITY WENT TO PAY MY RENT MY
DOCTOR PRESCRIBED FOODS THAT I
COULDN'T AFFORD. IT MUST FIRST
GO AHEAD OF ME THE BAD THE FOOD
CHEN MY DOCTOR RECOMMENDED
BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO BORROW THE
HEALTHY FOODS I LOST FIFTY
POUNDS. MY CHOLESTEROL AND GOT
MY LIFE BACK MARCH FOR OUR
SCHOOLS BEEN SO GOOD TO ME AND I
FEEL THAT AND SAVE MY LIFE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY I'M HAPPY. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY TO MISTER BARBER AT THIS
TIME WE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
COMMENT FOR THE THAT ARE
SUPPORT. OF AB TWO ONE FIVE
THREE FOR THOSE IN THIS ROOM.
WISH TO OFFER SUPPORT. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MOSES AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SCENE NO OTHERS- MISTER
OPERATOR- ARE THERE- TWO CALLERS
IN THE QUEUE TO OFFER- SUPPORT
COMMENTS. UP FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO ONE FIVE THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF. TWO ONE FIVE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE LINES IN Q. GROWING
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON HAIR RIVAS AND THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ELI TO GET
FROM THE FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
POLICY DIRECTOR AT CBRE- WE ARE
A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
PROUD. TO BE ONE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING IT AND WE HOPE THAT
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER HELLO AND. ONE I AM AGAIN
POLICY CENTER AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER THE
SHOPPER. PROVIDE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
JARED CALL WITH NEAREST
CALIFORNIA ALSO PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK. THANK YOU MR ROBERT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER CALLERS IN Q.
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF TWO
AB TWO ONE FIVE THREE. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIVE MORE
LINES WILL PUT A LINE. ITEM
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CASH GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RACHEL
MONICA OPEN SECOND HARVEST UNTIL
AGAIN VALLEY THEY'RE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE THANK YOU. YOU NEXT CALLER
. BUT ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS BETH MARKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOOD AND
FARMING NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO ONE FIVE THREE AND ALSO
ASKED TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS THE NATIONAL
YOUNG FARMERS COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON BECKY FILLED OUT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CALL OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THANK TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DEREK POLKA FROM THE LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL FOOD BANK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RICK SCOTT
THANK ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
MAX PERRY ON THE OP THE
ALBERTSONS COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT. BUT NO ADDITIONAL AND
AT THIS TIME. GAME IN FIGURES
OPERATOR AT THIS TIME WILL MOVE
TO- THERE'S NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION BUT IF THERE'S ANYONE
THIS ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS
CONCERNS OPPOSITION ALL THE TIME
TO DO SO. SEE NON OPERATOR THERE
ANY CALLERS IN THE QUEUE FOR-
SOME COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE FIVE THREE
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. IT MILLINGTON HERE AT
THIS TIME I THINK IT WAS ROBERT
AT THIS TIME ALL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. SEE NON- UP. THE
SERVICE. PROVIDER MATHIS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
AMARILLAS Y. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS ON THIS- MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE FRESH PRODUCE ESPECIALLY
CALIFORNIA AROUND- IN THESE
PROGRAMS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND I KNOW WE'VE WORKED ON.
THINGS LIKE THIS ROM THE STATE
IN THE PAST BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS
ONE. THANK OKAYDO NOT KNOW THE
COMMENTS- SEMINAR A FEW LIKE TO
CLOSE IN AS SOON AS WE STEPPED
QUORUM WITH ONE MORE. MEMBER OF
OUR COMMITTEE THEN WE WILL GET
THE BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK IS A MEMBER. THEN
AGAIN- IF THERE ARE ANY- MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE OUT THERE WISH
TO I DO US A SOLID SHOW UP THE
NEW GREAT- AND FOR THE FINAL
BILL ON OUR AGENDA. WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
MAIENSCHEIN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALKING DEAD COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IT'S GOOD TO BE
HERE THANK YOU CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY NINE ESTABLISHES THE
ORGANIC DRINK TRANSITION PILOT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE UNDERSERVED
FARMERS AND RANCHERS TOOLS TO
STAY IN BUSINESS WHILE PURSUING
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY FARMING
PRACTICES. THE ORGANIC
TRANSITION PROGRAM WILL SUPPORT
FARMERS AS THEY TRANSITION TO
ORGANIC FARMING BY FOCUSING ON
LIMITED RESOURCE AND SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED PRODUCERS AND
PROVIDING FINANCIAL AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO BECOME
CERTIFIED ORGANIC. UNDERSERVED
FARMERS FACE BARRIERS THAT LIMIT
THEIR ACCESS TO ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION AND MARKETS THESE
PRODUCED OFTEN MANAGE THEIR
BUSINESS ON THINNER MARGINS THAT
PREVENT THEM FROM ASSUMING
ADDITIONAL RISK AB TWENTY FOUR
NINE NINE TWENTY FOUR NINETY
NINE SEEKS TO ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES TO KEEP FARMERS IN
BUSINESS. I APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL ENGAGEMENT FROM THE
FARM BUREAU AND THE FOR TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AS REBEKAH
WEBER MARIE NORRIS. THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER- WAS WEBER WELCOME
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON. I
THINK YOU CHAIR RIVAS AND
ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
ON AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE.
MY NAME IS REBECCA WEBER ON THE
POLICY DIRECTOR I CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS OR CCO
HALF. WE REPRESENT THREE
THOUSAND ORGANIC FARMS RANCHES
AND BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS YOUR
FOUNDATION RUNS THE GRANT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
FARMERS THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES TO TRANSITION TO ORGANIC
AND MANY OF THE LEARNINGS FROM
THE SUCCESSFUL GRANT PROGRAM ARE
BAKED INTO TWENTY FOUR NINETY
NINE. I ASKED THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
NINE THIS BILL IS AIMED AT THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. OF
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED AND
LIMITED RESOURCE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. IT EXPANDS ON EXISTING
EQUITY PROGRAMS THAT CDFA. BY
PROVIDING FINANCIAL AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
UNDERSERVED FARMERS AND RANCHERS
TO TRANSITION TO ORGANIC. CDFA
IS TWENTY TWENTY FORMER EQUITY
ACT REPORT HIGHLIGHTS THAT
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND RANCHERS NEED GREATER ACCESS
TO RESOURCES. AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY NINE SEEKS TO FILL THIS
GAP BY PROVIDING FINANCIAL AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
TRANSITION TO ORGANIC. ORGANIC
SO FARMERS- EXCUSE ME. ORGANIC
ED IS A UNIQUE LABEL THAT
GUARANTEES THAT FOOD IS RAISED
AND GROWN USING ECOLOGICAL
PRACTICES ORGANIC FARMERS AND
RANCHERS ARE REQUIRED TO
CONSERVE SOIL WATER WETLANDS
WOODLANDS AND WILDLIFE. ORGANIC
CERTIFICATE HELPS FARMERS TO
STAY IN BUSINESS BY PROVIDING
MARKET OPPORTUNITY AS WELL AS
BEING ALIGNED WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS. WE HAVE HEARD FROM
UNDERSERVED FARMERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE CERTIFIED ORGANIC BUT
THAT THE TRANSITION PERIOD IS
TOO ONEROUS. HEAVING ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION IS NOT EASY
FARMERS CANNOT APPLY PROHIBITED
SYNTHETIC PESTICIDES AND
FERTILIZERS TO THE LAND FOR
THREE YEARS PRIOR TO TEIR FIRST
ORGANIC HARVEST. FARMERS MUST
MAKE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
INCLUDING SEED AND FEED LABOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. PREVENTATIVE
HEALTH CARE PRACTICES AND
ECOLOGICAL MANAGEMENT OF PESTS
WEEDS AND DISEASES. AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY NINE CREATES A PILOT
ORGANIC TRANSITION PROGRAM. TO
ENSURE THAT SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED AND LIMITED
RESOURCE FARMERS HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO ORGANIC CERTIFICATION
. THIS BILL ALSO CREATES A STATE
WIDE MARKET ANALYSIS OF YOUR CAN
EXPECT- WE KNOW FARMERS NEED A
CLEAR PICTURE. OF THE NEEDS AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF THE MARKET
PLACE FOR THEIR PRODUCTION PLANS
AS WELL AS FOR PROVING THE
FEASIBILITY OF THEIR BUSINESS
PLANS AND EXPANSION STRATEGIES
TO LENDERS. THIS INFORMATION
WILL HELP ALL FARMERS IDENTIFY
AND DEVELOP NEW MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES CSUF IS JOINED BY
FORTY TWO FOOD. FARMING AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- BUT
REALLY QUICKLY BEFORE- WE HAVE
OUR NEXT WITNESS ONE OF STATUS
QUORUMS AMOUNT SECRETARY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SHARE
RIVERS ARE HERE. MATHIS
AGUIAR-CURRY. LOSERS HERE TO
SENDING HIM. LAURA GRAY IRWIN
JONES SAWYER LEVINE COULD WHAT
WOULD I AM VERY QUICKLY IF I CAN
GET A PROMOTION- AND A SECOND
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY
MA'AM SECRETARY COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR JERRY THIS HI RIVAS I
AM MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA
LARA I GREAT IRWIN. IRWIN AYE
JONES SAWYER LEVINE BE A GOOD
LAW WOULD. WHAT I AND ALSO IF I
GET A MOTION SECOND FOR THE ITEM
WE JUST HEARD ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
ONE FIVE THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. MOTIONS SECOND-
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. ON AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE MOTION AS
DO PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIR RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE FLORA
FLORA I AGREE IRWIN IRWIN AYE
JONES SAWYER LEVINE VIA PUT LAW
WOULD. WOOD I. UNTESTED BILLS
OUT AND- WE'LL GO TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU HI GET
AFTERNOON TO REOPEN SOME REGRET
OVER MY NAME IS MONEY I'M NOT IS
I OWN- THAT IS ORGANIC
VEGETABLES LOOK AT IN SALINAS I
MEAN FOR ME IN OUR YOUNGER FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS. AND I'M HERE TO
ASK YOU TO THE BORY V. TWENTY
FOUR NINETY NINE WHICH CREATES
ORGANIZED TRANSECTION PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT AND UNDERSTAND FARMERS
RANCHERS- INTRANSIGENCE FARMERS
I WAS ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS OLD
WHEN I STARTED WORKING IN
AGRICULTURE I CAME FROM MAMA
REPORT FAMILY THAT HAS BEEN
WORK- IN FARM FOR AS LONG AS I
CAN REMEMBER. MY IMMIGRANT
PARENTS DO NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO ANYTHING ELSE
ON ON IN THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT KNOW HOW TO WRITE OR
READ. SPANISH OR ENGLISH. I IT'S
- FOR THAT THAT I AM. HERE TODAY
TO ASK YOU GUYS TO SUPPORT AT
TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE. I
CHOOSE TO GROW ORGANIC FOOD
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OF
ORGANIC PRACTICE- MY PASSIONATE
ABOUT ALSO YOU HILL AND
PROVIDING HEALTH FOOD FOR OUR
COMMUTE FOR MY COMMUNITY WHERE
WERE. I DID NOT ANTICIPATE. OUT
HOW DIFFICULT IT WOULD BE TO
START MY OWN FARM AND BECOME
ORGANIC CITY FREAK CERTIFIED
ORGANIC CERTIFICATION IT'S
EXPENSIVE. AND DIFFICULT TO
ASSESS ESPECIALLY FOR SOCIAL
DISADVANTAGE FARMERS WHO FACE
OUR LANGUAGE IN EDUCATION BEARS
LIKE ME. I NEED TO LEARN- A
pAND HOW TO MANAGE WE DO USE AN
ECOLOGICAL- APPROACHES THERE IS
SO MUCH MORE TO DO BY HAND- AND
WE NEED TO PURCHASE A SPECIAL-
MISSIONARY BECAUSE I WILL NOT.
USE SYMPTOMATIC COMMIT CALLS. ON
TOP OF- THESE ARE HIGH BECAUSE
IT'S BEING VERY DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE FARMING THROUGH ALL THE
YEARS BECAUSE- PEOPLE WILL OFTEN
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST ME AND ****
IN LAUNCH INFORMATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT HAS BEEN
VERY CHALLENGING. WE NEED AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE BECAUSE
FARMERS LIKE ME NEED MORE
SUPPORT AND ACCESS TO RESOURCES
AND I'LL MAKE YOU GUYS O.
SUPPORT A BILL TODAY- WILL BE A
RETURN. TO US- GALLAGHER THEY
HAVE A- AND SO AT THIS TIME WE
WILL- TAKE COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR NINE
NINE- SO THOSE WHO HERE DOES
FIVE AS TIME DO SO. HELLO MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS MELISSA
GUN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM AND THE SAID ACTION
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARKETS
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST THE CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE
AND AN RTC AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
. HI THIS IS ANNA LARSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN SUPPORT
SIX THANK YOU. SEE NO OTHER TO
SEE NO OTHER- IN PERSON AS
COMMENTS- MISTER OP WRITER ARE
THEIR COLORS IN THE QUEUE. A TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS TO SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR NINE NINE
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE LINES IN Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL JARED
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS AND
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SACRAMENTO
NINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANGEROUS
LEADERSHIP COMPANY BIRDS OF THE
CALEDONIAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. FIND FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD- I
THINK THAT MADE ME I APOLOGIZE
THIS IS THE BEST MOGUER AGAIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOOD AND
FARMING NETWORK AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MR ROBERT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER BECAUSE THE
QUEUE- FOR COME TO SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR NINE NINE
. THE WONDERFUL ALIGNMENT
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS AMIRA I HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THE SPELL BUT I MOSTLY JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS MY SHEET
ADMINSTRATION AND FISHING ON
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU OPERATOR
PLEASE. OR PLEASE ENTER THE COME
IS ON PROBATE- ONLY. ONCE IN
COMMENTS- FOR- THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR NINE
NINE. NEXT CALL PLEASE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER LINES AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU STOP WRITERS AT THIS
TIME WILL TAKE ANY- COMMENTS
THAT HAVE CONCERN OPPOSITION TO
SEND THE BILL TO FOUR NINE NINE.
NOW TO THE TIME TO MAKE THOSE
COMMENTS. OR. REMEMBER STILL
RUSSIAN WITH THE CALVARY FROM
THERE WERE A BIT OF A TWEENER
HERE WE SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
CONCERN FOR THE RECORD- I WANNA
BE CLEAR WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE THEORY IF A FARMER WANTS TO
MAKE A DECISION TO TRANSITION TO
ORGANIC WE WANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE
OF IT BECAUSE FOR EXACTLY THE
REASONS THE WITNESSES MENTIONED
IT'S TOUGH TO BE ORGANIC. I'M
SORRY ONE OF PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT WHERE WE CAN AND I THINK
THE STATE CAN PLAY AN ACTIVE
ROLE IN THAT. THE CONCERN IS
REALLY TWO FOLD ONE ON
PROGRAMMATIC FUNCTIONS OR
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM.
AND THE SECOND IS ON PRESIDENT-
TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE PROPOSES
TO PLACE THE PROGRAM FOR
TRANSITION TO ORGANIC IN THE
FORMER EQUITY OFFICE OR WITH THE
FARMER EQUITY ADVISER-
UNDERSTANDABLY. THAT MIGHT BE
THE FIRST POINT OF CONTACT FOR
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND RANCHERS BUT WE DO FEEL AS
THOUGH IT HAS A BETTER HOME AND
EITHER THE STATE ORGANIC
PROGRAM- WHERE IT RELLY COVERS
THE PANOPLY OF OPTIONS AROUND
ORGANIC CERTIFICATION
REGISTRATIONS. OR THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING INNOVATION
WHICH THIS LEGISLATURE JUST GAVE
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO LAST
YEAR TO TRANSITION TO ORGANIC. I
AND SO WE FEEL AS THOUGH. THOSE
TWO PLACES ARE BUT- FOR PROGRAM
LIKE THIS WITH. INCOMES WITH THE
EQUITY OFFICER. RATHER CONCERN
IS ONE OF PRESIDENT- WINS
AGUIAR-CURRY PASSED THE FARM
EQUITY ACT IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. OUR UNDERSTANDING WAS
THAT THE AT THE OFFICE WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR EMBEDDING THE
PRINCIPLES OF DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION AT THE PROGRAMMATIC
GRASSROOTS LEVEL. THAT WE EACH
PROGRAMS EQUITY COMPONENTS TAKEN
TO IT- WITH THAT'S APTLY HAPPEN
IT'S HARD WORK. TENSION ALL
WORK- ARE CONCERNED. EIGHTY
NINE. BUT IT MIGHT THE MESSAGE.
ABSOLUTELY ON AND- THE- THE
EITHER THAT COULD BE THE WORK
ISN'T BEING TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND
ISN'T BEING DONE IN EARNEST. OR
THAT IF IS THERE IS A BENCH
FARMER A RANCHER HAS A CHALLENGE
WITH THE FARMER FACING PROGRAM
AT THE GOVERNMENT ALLOWED LEVEL.
THEIR ONLY RECOURSE IS TO NOT
ADDRESS THE PROGRAM IN QUESTION
BUT TO GO TO THE FORMER EQUITY
POSITION AND RE CREATE A NEW
PROGRAM. THAT SERVES THEM THERE.
I THINK OUR PERSPECTIVE AT FARM
BUREAU IS THAT EVERYONE DESERVES
A SEAT AT THE TABLE. AND THE
TABLE NOT BIG ENOUGH YOU DON'T
BUILD A NEW TABLE FOR SOMEBODY
ELSE. YOU MAKE THE TABLE BIGGER
YOU SCOOCH DOWN TO MAKE ROOM. SO
I THINK OUR CONCERN IS THAT- THE
PROGRAM IS REALLY. ILL PLACE TO
REALLY SERVICE THE FULL SUITE OF
NEEDS THAT AN ORGANIC PRODUCER
OR SH ONE DAVE ORGANIC PRODUCER
WOULD REALLY NEED SO- CONCERNED
WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN EARNEST
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS
OF THEY'VE BEEN INCREDIBLY%
GENEROUS WITH THEIR TIME. SO WE
HOPE TO FIND A PATHWAY FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS- AT THIS TIME THERE ANY
OTHER. MEMBERS IN THIS ROOM. WAS
BRIGHT COMMENTS. SEEN ON THE
SHOP RIGHT ARE THERE ANY CALLERS
IN THE QUEUE. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. TO ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FOUR NINE NINE. CLEVELAND THIS
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME I
THANK YOU MR OPERATOR THIS TIME
A BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
AGREE YEAH I HAVE I HAVE A
COMMENT. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR AND
I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. I JUST HAVE A POINT TO
MAKE AND I HOPE YOU'LL WORK ON
IT GOING FORWARD. WHEN I CREATED
THE FARM EQUITY. OF VISOR IN THE
FORMER EQUITY ACT I WORK FOR THE
SECRETARY WALK ACROSS TO HAVE A
POSITION. UP TO HAVE A POSITION
WITH THE EXPRESS PURPOSE OF
ADDING INPUT ON ISSUES AND
EVERYONE OF OUR CDFA IS
PROGRAMS. AND AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD WITH WHAT I HOPE BECOMES
A NEW LAW. I HOPE YOU'LL CONSULT
WITH THE SECRETARY ON HOW TO
DESIGNATE THE INTO THE-
IMPLEMENTATION PERHAPS SIMPLY.
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT-
SO THAT WE CAN BE SURE THIS
PROGRAM DOES NOT HAMPER THE CORE
MISSION OF THE FARMER EQUITY
OFFICER. IN PROVIDING FEEDBACK
ACROSS ALL DEPARTMENTS. ON THE
PROGRAMS- I WOULD APPRECIATE YOU
WOULD CONSIDER THAT. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS WE AUTHOR. WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
SUMMATION YOU ARE AT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS AGUIAR-CURRY-
ABSOLUTELY WILL CONTINUE ORDER
AS AS YOU'VE HEARD WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR A WHILE I
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO- AND WITH
THAT AS CHAIR MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU- AND SO WE DO HAVE A
MUCH AS I CAN. I'M SICK TO BE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- CHAIR RIVAS. RIVAS
AYE MATHIS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE FLORA. OR NOT
VOTING GRAY. GRAY I IRWIN IRWIN
AYE JONES SAWYER I WITH A TIE
FUTURE HOME SOMEWHERE I'D-
LEVINE YEP WOULD WALK ME
VALLAPUDUA I WOULD. WOOD I THINK
BILLS UP AT THIS TIME THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING WE WILL
TAKE UP- MISSY VOTES OR CONSENT
CALENDAR AND SECONDARY. CONSENT
CALENDAR GREAT. ADAM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADAM WAKE UP GREAT ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. VERY AYE JONES
SAWYER I AM SAWYER AYE LEVINE
WILL BE ABLE TO WALK BAREFOOT DR
. THEY ARE ALSO MISSING VOTES
FOR US IN THE BILL FILE ITEM NO
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE FIVE
THREE ARAMBULA. ON AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE- GRAY. MISTER GRAY
WE'RE TAKING BOATS A- GRAY EYED
JONES SAWYER HI THERE I. LEVINE
VIA PUT OFF BE APPROVED WHILE I
. OKAY ALSO SO THAT- BILLS THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME MISTER
CHAIR. WE'RE GOING TO BE. ARE
WAY DOWN. I WILL BE ABLE TO
DEFEND IT YEAH. WHO'S GOING OF
THE SHE WAS OUR- GERMANY'S ALL
AND THAT I GOT OUT THERE OF THE
POLICY. NEXT SUMMER. YEAH
RESIDENTS ARE OF GOVERNMENT
OFFICE. I WILL. CRISTINA THANK
YOU SO. RESPONDED. TO THIS-
ARAMBULA. HI.